ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dyan show we're sorry we are a little
late just getting back from uh Australia
as always uh the spirit of Princess
Diana is with us hello hi hi Princess
Diana how are you I'm good are you
seeing what's going on in our world
right now yes and I believe in a
Palestinian State because I was killed
by the Jews in a tunnel hey hey hey
Princess Diana is out of her mind
I was killed by Jews in a tunnel
hey anyway two guests are here that
don't uh know what I'm going to say and
don't have the money to withstand the
attacks and hatred not at all that uh I
don't you know but they're good friends
of mine uh Mike Canon Mike FY great
comics from New York who have been
hanging out for the last few days um and
Los Angeles California while the world's
falling apart yeah man just seeing what
you live like we've been having fun yeah
we've been having a good time went down
to the beach jumped in the ocean almost
got swept away by the currents it was
very but you know when you see like how
I live it's just like it's just New York
lives a certain way yeah and everybody's
used to it and when you come out here
everyone can live like this uh no I
don't think
everybody I don't think everybody parks
in a Red Zone and then just flicks
everybody off and it's like tow it I
don't care seura did this the other day
don't you fear that the obsession with
rules is a Bourgeois middle class
mentality yes like this is the reality
I've known a lot of successful people
they have no respect for rules they have
no respect for rules right yeah Israel
no I'm kidding I'm kidding you stop it
you stop it now stop hello but they do
they were attacked we're getting to that
the point is I don't get caught up in it
because I say I'm parking my car where
there is [__] curb space that's it
the the middle class following rules
isn't that part of the reinforcement of
public schooling they're trying to keep
you in the Cog that you came in here's
what happens I I had my fat family to my
home over the over the summer and
they're lovely people but they were all
like can you park by the beach without a
permit you don't have a permit what's
going to happen they're going to tow it
they're going to give you a ticket and
it's just like that and they don't yeah
it's the fear it's the fear that these
people walk around with all day and
nothing happens yeah here's what happens
most of the time nothing every now and
then yes could you get towed yes could
you get a ticket yes who gives a [__]
the reality is you should learn how and
when you can break the rules and then at
the end of the day you you choose where
you can break the rules is that not does
that soundra crazy no it doesn't sound
crazy it does sound like you can weather
a few the fin the financial storm but
you got but you can only get there if
you don't care if you're afraid all the
time you'll never make money you'll
never do anything it's tough not to care
I went through three years of watching
Comics not say anything and not earn a
dollar because you were waiting to get
jobs on a fake TV show that never
happened and they were like I can't have
an opinion about anything because I
won't get on this thing that isn't real
it's not even real anymore they're not
even making these shows these people are
eating on the street they have their
[__] on Craigslist and for three years
they were fearful and afraid of
everything so my whole point is that you
shouldn't be afraid to just
live I got my car to to Malibu we got
them as they were not today but the
other day we got them they dropped the
was I paid the drop fee I rode in the
tow truck it was fun the guy was cool a
fan saw me in the tow truck I waved to
the guys inim getting towed you know I
he was like why are you getting towed
I'm like the you know the [__]
government and [__] yeah it's the
government why aren't you getting towed
you rule following [__] yeah I mean
it's just I my parents were so terrified
of everything they were so scared and
that's why my father drove a Pontiac
Sundance because he was terrified of
like ever like you know yeah he's like
well you can't they were so afraid
they're like don't let it because they
were afraid of getting sued they thought
all my friends were going to kill
themselves in the pool don't let anyone
in the pool here somebody's going to
slip on the deck and we'll get sued or
trampolines remember we had a trampoline
in your backyard you're like I can't
afford the insurance on that yes it
because were your parents paranoid about
people getting sued Well yeah if they if
someone broke their neck on a trampoline
our we grew up with just this idea that
like every friend we had was a
liability potential liability don't let
him get on the trampoline don't let him
get in the pool they have asthma they
would identify the kid with asthma
they'd be be like he has asthma watch
him my parents wouldn't even get a pool
cuz they didn't want our house to be
welcoming interesting yeah they just
wanted every activity all social
Gatherings were outside the home the
idea that we might throw a party was
completely far they never left well
remember the show Rescue 911 that was on
there was a show called res 911 that and
N Nanny 911 it was all about people who
had accidents in their homes and and it
would be like a a kid who like hit his
head and his paral in the pool get the
Rescue 911 yeah this guy and this would
terrify people William Shatner William
Shatner this was Shatner yeah it was
Shatner and then this would terrify
Boomers to into thinking that like their
house was just booby trapped yeah and
that literally someone was G to one of
your kids friends was going to die in it
and you were going to get sued pull up
like a Rescue 911 see if we can get like
an idea of what it was it was always
like it would be like there was a
drowning she took her eyes off the water
for a
second and then there was a Dr yeah like
this is what it was there could have
been a Rescue 911 with oh my God what is
going on
here just the Middle East my my mom had
a cousin or at least this was her story
that was a black belt and he jump dove
into a 4- foot pool and paralyzed
himself everyone has it I never met a
single athletic cousin that she's ever
had yeah everyone has a story of a guy
who jumped in head first like people
used to jump off go to the the beginning
with the ambulance is just coming I love
the opening see yeah let's see the
opening this is what just Boomers watch
just fear yeah this was they watch this
this program contains true stories of
rescues all of the 911 calls you will
hear are real whenever possible the
actual people involved have helped us
reconstruct the events as they happened
great
[Laughter]
diction right away somebody in my house
everyone's
dying this is 911 do you have an
emergency what if your kids's friends
choked to death and you're on the hook
you're on the hook you're on the hook
you're footing the bill you were
drinking wine in the back room and your
daughter and her friend were raped how
about that it was a group raping and you
were drunk in your room all right all
right enough of that is this the'80s
feels like yeah it's what the it was the
' 80s or not but that people were so
paranoid about uh you know and it was
never because they were like your friend
is a good person we would hate if they
drown yeah it was always like we didn't
want them to cost us money if that if
that if we went out in those waves a
little bit farther there would have been
a Rescue 911 of me calling 911 that Tim
Dylan just got swept out to see today
that would have been like they would
have rejoy this they would have rejoiced
Gavin new would have had like a glass of
wine sign an ninal ceasefire yeah that
would be amazing
the hostages are relas everything would
be great the Twin Towers build back one
by
one everybody loves it um like we tried
to swim but I you know and we're strong
swimmers but it was rough yeah I feel
like that's a good death for you though
dying in Malibu at a beautiful beach it
feels like a I want to kill a lot of
people when I die I want to kill a lot
of people take them with you I want to
kill a lot people when I die whatever
that's too hard to something something
big yeah something you know so what do
you guys what are you guys who are you
muzzies or Jew what are you at right now
go on the record Mike Mike Canon on
Twitter what are you Mikey Muslims or
Jews go on the record now who is it I
you know team
peace w
wow okay that's a member of the lgbtq
community here who I actually I don't
think any of the children of either side
need water that's what here's what I'm
worried about that's a great Point
here's what I'm worried about um even if
this all ends tomorrow I feel like
people in that air in that region are
gonna hate each other for a long time
like it's just there's no hope of this
of a Reconciliation right right it
doesn't feel that way it doesn't feel
like it it's kind of it it goes you know
when is it going to be like Palestinians
and Israelis having like hot sex there's
got to be some
that's for sure under like a taboo por
porn category for sure there's got to be
when are when are they going to walk
Gaza with like the Bloods and Crips with
the blue and the red handkerchief tied
together and just be like guys it's over
I mean hopefully the end of the week but
it doesn't seem like it that'd be nice
no I mean I I I worry about you know
people that are that are living there
are they going to be able to because
everyone wants to be fun and cool you
know and and it's just not like I feel
for the kids that are growing up in Gaza
and I feel for the kids that are growing
up in Israel that are like not you know
like their lives now are just completely
shattered you
know yeah that's awful yeah no it's
truly a terrible awful thing I don't
know agree yeah hard hard agree it's
strongly
I got to speak out for the people you
have to use your platform for the
because there's a lot of people over
there right now let's be honest not for
nothing there's a lot of people over
there right
now hurting and they're in and they're
in pain and it's not nice
no and what I would like to say is stop
it yeah right to who yeah what to whom I
say stop it to all the blanket stop it
well I say it to everyone smart you know
me and my cousins used to throw each
other down the stairs sure during
Thanksgiving and you know what my Aunt
Carol would say she'd have a glass of
wine and she St and we'd go but he did
it they did it and she'd go everyone
stop it everyone stop it you're
disrespecting nanny's house stop it now
and that's kind of what the energy here
the energy here is is is just cut it out
you're acting like a bunch of
Knuckleheads and dodo
birds but
who's that's what my grandfather was say
you're being a bunch of doo birds who's
the grandmother in this situation
Biden Iran I don't know
Syria I have no idea Joe Biden and his
individually closing eyes yeah I mean
here's what we went to a great
restaurant last night AA shout out to AA
uh in Beverly Hills Kim Kardashian
having her party a couple of blocks away
at Funk uh which I wasn't invited to
which is fine it's okay uh Kim
cardashian there with Ivanka Trump and
other lovely people and luminaries
celebrating Haley Bieber and all of that
and uh we were as importantly having our
own event lobster pasta at Ava which is
a great Mediterranean resta in Beverly
Hills I have one in New York shout out
to the manager in New York who always
takes care of me wasn't in Beverly Hills
the other night that's okay but let's
remember that when I go back in um but
we were there and everybody's Arabs or
Jews in Beverly Hills everyone's Persian
they're either Jewish or Arab and they
all look alike and everyone's kind of
being very quiet white BMW Galore yeah
it's very you know and so we're all
sitting there looking at them going
which one are you and right doesn't
isn't that what you were doing that's
what I was doing
I was looking around the restaurant
going which one are you because you all
kind of have the nose uhoh you're all
well they do and they're all kind of tan
and they're all rich yeah and I'm like
what wealth and it's you just got to say
one thing to them to kind of find out
what's that thing you just sit down next
to either one of them and you
goof been a long time
coming now depends what they think I
mean the Hamas attack or the
obliteration of Gaza the counter attack
but when you say been a long time coming
over
there then they get to take the lead the
first thing they say will lead you to
their opinion of course absolutely and
we'll know which one they are yeah
you're putting out some Middle East
breadcrumbs that's right yeah because we
are what religion are you Irish Catholic
yeah me too what about you same same
we're not in it boys yeah we're not in
it outside our people are pro Palestine
the Irish they are the Irish Catholics
are is that true yeah CU they were but I
thought we were pro-israel because
they're protecting the place where Jesus
comes back no because we feel like a
similar like because of Northern Ireland
and and the British and the IRA we feel
very like a kinship with the
Palestinians I don't no per se okay I I
no I'm saying this I the only reason I
don't feel a kinship with the
Palestinians is because I am more of an
American than I am Irish of course yeah
because I don't have that thing I'm not
saying the Palestinians are wrong I'm
saying that I don't the Irish have that
experience with Britain in the UK I
don't sure yeah I'm just glad you're
saying something because silence is
violence I'm saying it all yeah no I
said today I said Israel should do a
ceasefire but the Palestinian release
all the hostages they should release all
of the hostages and then there should be
a ceasefire and then we should do I
talked about at a big [__] concert T
Swift Ed shear and Drake massive massive
concert massive concert like a We are
the world we are the children thing
massive concert you're telling me Ed
Sheeran can't get up there with a guitar
and fix this is a little repeater thing
that he's got Salon the hill you're
telling me that that sewer rat the
problem can't get up there the problem
is guitar I think they're a little guny
of music festivals right now Mike that's
I should we have them on the show that
was disgusting gunai was inappropri the
fact that you would say that that is
disgusting and
disrespectful uh no I agree with you
apparently it
is it is um it is odd that you would I
would suggest that a musical thing would
help they've had concerts in Vegas I'm
just saying we need need that energy of
do we need that energy or not of this
this is the energy we kind of need
coming together that's what we
deescalation maybe do it a the world
maybe do it a little further from from
Gaza this time yeah Inland it's got to
be some metal detectors some security
yeah you know but
Drake you know Drake has been oddly
quiet about this whole thing considering
he's half involved right that's
interesting yeah he doesn't really speak
up he's got an album to push
well you know what it is it's um
probably
difficult because he
probably sees both sides of it and he's
big in the Arab world oh yeah right yeah
he's massive yeah but he's also
Jewish he's big in the whole world in
every part of the world true but
specifically with regard to this
conflict right his standing in Iceland
is
immaterial you know what I mean it's
we're talking more about his
relationship to those people the
Arabs so he's you know I
mean this you know they try get this up
they're trying to get Bill Gates is
trying they want to kick the leaders of
Hamas out of the Four Seasons in DOA
guar here's what I say to that there's
not a lot of good hotels in this world
there's very few of them and the Four
Seasons has consistency it has good
betting it has room service that is
pretty damn good I don't know if we need
to go kick Hamas out of the Four Seasons
in DOA qar they have a standing
room well they have cond well they have
condos in the Four Seasons that they
live in representative Mike Waltz
demands Bill Gates ban Hamas from Qatar
Four Seasons representative Mike Waltz
is calling on billionaire Bill Gates to
step in and ban Hamas terrorists from
using any of the Four Season hotels
including one of the companies
properties in Qatar noting that the
Microsoft co-founder and former CEO has
a controlling stake in the hotel chain
through his investment firm hamas's
political Wing has previously hosted
events at the Four Season Hotel in DEA
including a 2016 reception with then
Turkish prime minister
AMT good
luck yeah I mean and but so here's the
deal Qatar is very interesting right
because Qatar is like this you know
Middle Eastern country but it's
westernized didn't they have the World
Cup right they have all that stuff
happen they killed thousands of slaves
while they built their Stadium yeah well
but was did you see yeah yeah it was
good beautiful but this is what I mean
seemed hot we you know slaves also built
the White House right right I mean a
long time ago but it you know you can't
you know what is the thing about the
omelet and and the Egg and the got to
break a few you got to break a few eggs
and slaves you have to break a few
slaves make an omelet to get a stadium
the point is the point is the Arab world
is going out there and they're saying we
are the future we're going to have great
big sporting events when they say can we
do the Olympics in Los Angeles you know
what the sick [__] here say no we can't
because we have too many homeless people
we can't move so we can't so the qar and
all these places are going like we come
here yeah we will host the biggest
events the biggest UFC the World Cup
we're ready put us in coach and then
cities like La cannot get enough people
they can't keep them from [__] in
the street long enough so somebody could
do the pole
vault it's disgusting so here's what
I'll say Hamas is not good and what they
did was barbaric but the political wing
of Hamas has been staying in the Four
Seasons for a very long time here's the
way I feel about brand
loyalty this is the way I feel about
brand loyalty I I believe in it as a
concept and I believe that not only do
you value a brand but a brand should
value you MH and if Hamas is going to
bring money into the Four Seasons in DOA
and do events and do the make your own
waffle yeah when they do the when they
bring the Turkish prime minister in and
they're going to do the omelet station
we know how it goes we have the omelet
station we have make your own waffle you
know if Hamas is going to utilize that
then I don't know if who are we to say
you know well and it's a slippery slope
what's next the Yakuza are going to be
ejected from a hotel not my
hotel by the way I've stayed in very
highend hotels for a very long time and
the the the people that say they are
primarily criminals and we and thank you
because without money laundering without
murder and killing and there's no nice
anything yeah there's nothing nice
without death and that's not popular to
say but it is true if you see marble
there's blood
somewhere I mean you you know you don't
get diamonds without blood diamond so
here's what I'm saying I'm saying that I
think that the political wing of Hamas
if they have I mean where are you on
this why am I always come on where Hamas
Hamas in the Four Seasons Mike P Hamas
in the four SE we're going to put this
right on the Hamas in the Four Seasons
go well I think you make uh interesting
points Tim I uh I do I do enjoy peace I
do think that brand loyalty is important
but uh you know like you said Hamas is
not how about how about a nice stop it a
stop it but but should they be allowed
should Hamas be allowed to stay in the
Four Seasons yeah yes by the way I think
they should yes why not because you know
again that's right again where does it
stop and if they're like put them into a
holiday in or somewhere less comfortable
how much are they they're going to
urgently do something going be worse of
it if you take me out of the Four
Seasons I'm get my fat accid and power
glider tomorrow dude if
you it won't even get off the ground
embarrassing will that be I have to roll
in in a
barrel if you uh this episode's our
final one
yeah if you take them off a a sweet
Memory Foam bed and put them on a hard
Motel 6 cot yeah no by the way putting
them in a [__] hotel is not going to
make it better dummy this is how dumb
our government this is how dumb our
government is our government's like get
their scrambled eggs out of their mouth
like it's like funny you got a
geopolitical crisis it's not fruit cup
that we're worried about exactly you
have Iran about to get into the war with
Hezbollah you have China with destroyers
in the south in the in the in the Middle
East whatever the [__] thing is you
have Russia uh that's backing uh you
know certain militias out there that
don't like us we have a whole Brew thing
Brewing here that's a real big World War
III scenario and this guy's like get him
out of the bed it's got him start with
their thread count we
have is it Egyptian cotton it's crazy
this is your solution to World War II
get them out of the Four Season this is
just a person trying to say literally
anything without commenting on the war
and just being like what if we just what
if we just get him out of there that's
my listen to this the Four Seasons in an
October 15 statement
said hania who's the Hamas guy is not
living or staying at the Four Seasons
Hotel DOA but did not immediately
respond to the post request for comment
about the length of his previous day so
he's not even there they just don't want
well he is but yeah
but that's the thing I checked out he
checked out he dropped his key in the
slot we haven't seen it and by the way
you know cuz this is awkward but you
know how nice he probably is to
everybody I bet he tips well you know
what I mean you know how nice he is I'm
not saying he's a good person yeah but
I'm saying he's nice he's probably very
nice so he's probably got people lying
for him going like yeah yeah yeah he uh
he Mr Ana he's just check he check out
isn't that a kind of outside of
everything it it does seem like kind of
a security concern if he is is staying
there oh it will be yeah oh yeah cuz I
mean the mad's going to get it on and
shout out to the mad and I respect what
they're going to do they're going to go
assassinating people everybody's got to
get a shout out here that's a reality
yeah um but they are not going to take
this line that that's why all the idiots
who are just like free Palestine that's
a fine perspective to have but also
understand that like Israel is not going
to completely roll over after their
citizens are slaughtered sure that's
just not going that's not a realistic
thing the world is the way it is now you
may not like that the Palestinians don't
have a state I would agree and say that
it's not a sustainable situation and is
barbaric and they've been living in that
but this idea that Israel is just not
going to respond is crazy that's crazy
so this is what it is you know this is a
real big [__] mess especially from a
country who loves responding in an
over-the-top way they respond we do and
we do yeah big time it's kind of our
thing we we were kind of the best at but
does doesn't this feel very kind of post
911 though in the messaging that they're
trying to get us to support this [__]
which is like us against evil us against
the good guy was also Russia you know
all of the all of the whole election was
like Russia installed Trump Russia's
evil then it was Russia and the Ukraine
we got to fight Russia and now it's
China China we gotta fight China we're
fighting North Korea for a minute there
we're fighting North Korea it's there's
always an enemy and if there's not an
enemy there's an enemy in the wings yeah
it's there's an enemy in the wings like
we're kind of we test out enemies we see
if they work they focus group enemies
focus group
enemies like Syria never caught on we're
like we don't really
nah because we were we were going into
Syria getting rid of the Libyan State
and the Syrian State meanwhile Isis is
running around Syria yeah so then Russia
we are arming Isis to fight Russia and
we're arming Isis to fight the Assad
family who run Syria again they're not
great but they had a government we're
we're arming militias to fight the
Syrian government and the Libyan
government and then we turn around and
go got to get tough with terrorism it's
like we're g we gave them all the money
but it's like a therapist giving shitty
advice on purpose yes they always come
back we need them we need them need them
just enough just enough advice to keep
coming back no we need them and and we
need them we need these groups of PE and
it really is that's what it is yeah we
just go around that part of the world
handing out missiles getting people
going
jinting people and then eventually one
of them gets big enough to [__] with us
and then we go out you know who we are
we're the guy in the bar that goes over
to one drunk guy and he goes you know
that guy's talking [__] about you like
pinches his girlfriend's ass and then
Fades into the back great Bill Hicks bit
about like pick up the gun you know like
Shane the like pick up the gun like Jack
Palance being like you saw him he had a
gun you know but I just I hope this
whole thing uh I hope this whole thing
works out and you know me I I don't pull
any punches but I'll tell you this
wacky and stop it wacky and stop and
I'll tell you this right now let's go to
some good news for a change Argentina
Court acquits none in deaf children sex
abuse case thank you good news wow good
news the death kids were
[Laughter]
lying two nuns and seven other female
employees of an Argentine Institute for
Deaf children were acquitted by a court
Wednesday of sexual abuse and rape the
ruling broadcast on public television
concluded a trial of 2 and a half years
in a case that has shocked the home
country of Pope
Francis two priests in charge of the
children at the Antonio Prolo Center
Horatio kuarto and Nicola karate have
been
convicted that's kind of
close well how would you pronounce it
that actually is exactly it no but it's
I've been convicted and handed sentences
of more than 40 years for sexual abuse
including rape of 20 minor see the
Catholic Church it's not great the
victims were 4 to 17 Jesus Christ when
the crimes were committed the
institution's gardener Armando Gomez has
also been jailed for 18 years why do
they not go for Life by the way I don't
understand why they're it's 18 years
yeah several staff were taken into
custody after allegations of abuse first
surfaced um why are they still referring
to them as crimes even though they were
commit acquitted so no no no these
people all went to jail I think keep
going down because we're gonna get
to
um okay hold on hold on here we go here
we go go
up um a little bit more the latest case
focused on the alleged abuse of 11 to
the children in the dock where Japanese
nun Kumiko kosaka and paraguayan as asan
Martinez as well as a former cook a
psychologist a legal representative and
a School director and three other
employers kak stood accused of
aggravated sexual abuse and covering up
the crimes and Martinez of Corruption of
miners among the other alleged offenses
a panel of three judges on Wednesday
acquitted them MH they were all
acquitted of the um the abuse of the
death so those two okay the rest well
the the um Ariel lazara the father of
one of the accusers describe the outcome
as a total
[Laughter]
Injustice well they know I don't know
they maybe they know somebody on the
inside they're just saying that deaf
kids are unfuckable they're that's kind
of what they're saying they saying
they're Liars they're Liars by their
nature the de but this is a good this is
the good news this week because
everything else is bad yeah so this is
good the deaf children that were abused
were not abused by these people right no
somebody got them that is true but not
these guys so like I always you know
it's a silver lining on the cloud of the
Catholic Church yeah you don't want you
don't want wrongful imprisonment that's
no good no I mean I mean I don't know
man arrested for faking heart attack 20
times at restaurants to avoid paying
bill mean that's this guy in my mind
yeah is an American hero he is I think
he did it in
Spain this man in my opinion is a
Spanish hero he's an American hero that
he's 50 years old he was from Lithuania
and he was arrested in Spain in my
opinion is a Lithuanian hero yeah I mean
it's it's it's funny that by the way
it's a lot to fake a heart attack yeah
yeah that's an that's like a physical
effort you're also getting an ambulance
to come you're like you're making a SC
it's not thing nobody could do that to
America because it would be more money
to have a fake heart attack than pay the
bill ambulance is like 1500 bucks people
with real heart attacks go put me in an
Uber
afford so in Europe I guess you can just
fake heart attacks I guess maybe they
got him in a car does it say how he did
it like did they smuggle him into a car
or something the man attempted to leave
it without paying but the restaurant
staff stopped him and noted how he still
needed to pay the bill um the scammer
became visibly upset and said he was
going to get the money from his hotel
room when staff refused to let him leave
without paying the man dramatically
threw himself on the ground and
pretended to have a heart attack not
fooled the staff called the police and
instead of an ambulance the man was
recognized by local
authorities that's that's a tough dis
Mount from Faking that to then kind of
looking around and noticing nobody's
buying it and then being like I've had
this exact situation happened I worked
at an Applebees and there was a woman
who threw purel on the floor when she
went to the bathroom and I love it at
every stage of your life yeah you could
have done something better and just
didn't like there was no reason for you
to ever work at an apple big no ever in
your life no it's the craziest thing in
the world how old were you oh it was it
it was right after there's so many
better restaurants better places it was
all right I figured out how to add Auto
gratuity it was okay but um but I it was
yeah I was there a few months and
literally the person threw PRL on the
ground as they went to the bathroom when
they came out of the bathroom she looked
both ways didn't even pretend to slip
she laid down slowly in it on the ground
and started screaming the manager
because I guess this happens a lot
espey like especially at an Applebees uh
the the manager checked the security
footage saw all of it and she was like I
want my meal comped I want to eat here
for free for the rest of my life all
these demands and she goes all right I
just watched the security tape you're
full of [__] we're going to call the
police and then she goes all right well
then like at least a free dessert right
that so that was her bargaining chip and
the woman's like I'm calling the police
and she's like here's the money and
extra for tip and I'm so sorry well I
there's something fun and I've always
respected people that commit to
something and the idea of going out to
Applebees and eating the food knowing
that you're gonna have to do that a two
for2 meal that's two appetizers two
Entre for $20 no she was with another
person okay so $10 she's on the line for
$10 but it's so funny to just turn
around to that other person when they
start to get out their wallet and you go
no no no no no this I got this it's on
me I this it's on purel no it's it there
is something distinctly American about
trying to get out of especially a
restaurant Bill we dine and dash when we
were little kids we would run out of
Boulder Creek steakhouse in Hicksville
and just run out once at Fridays I I
I've probably told this story before the
waitress was very vicious and rude she
was a very rude person sure because she
worked at Fridays so that's true but
hcap yeah perhaps that she created yeah
yeah and we were sitting there me and a
bunch of my friends and she was very
rude so I told them all to leave and
then I just went back in because you
know Fridays it's hectic I just went in
and grabbed all the money out of the
thing and I I got back in the car went
hi the sleeve oh yeah yeah I got in the
car and I just turned to my friend's
brother I went go go go go and I started
handing everyone back their money I'm
like here's your 20 here's your 20
here's your 20 and we were all just
laughing it was a great night sure we um
I think they make them pay for it oh
yeah they definitely think that woman
had to pay the money out it goes out of
their thing for sure we used to do that
at the Blauvelt Diner and uh where's
that in Rockland County in blel and we
had similar 3:00 a.m. we weren't
drinking yet we were younger but this
waitress being you know she didn't want
we were ordering [__] right so she
was so mean that we ended up paying her
but leaving the cash in the milkshake on
the table and dipping it to the point
where we left it like a few bucks short
too so it wasn't even like exact but we
change at the bottom of the milkshake
the whole thing walked out and she's
slamming on the window as we were
running away here the thing they had to
do that now I tip so well I overdo it I
tip crazily I'm good but when you're
teen teenager there is a time in your
life when it is completely appropriate
really to do things like that to destroy
someone's day it's it's really
appropriate when you are a teenager to
to do things like that occasionally
because when you get older you cannot do
that petty crime is real fun you know
flipping out a little bit and doing
something crazy like trying to get out
of a restaurant without paying as a
teenager I think is okay yeah I mean I
think it's okay I was we were constantly
doing a with money and stuff it wasn't
like that but we would constantly damage
[__] yeah we committed a lot of crime
pulling fences out of the ground oh dude
it was the best P pull down
basketballs egging cars paper paintball
houses we would throw eggs you know
there was there was people that worked
at B's B's Total Fitness sure there was
a big window and they'd be like running
on treadmills and we we would like throw
eggs at them and many of them didn't
even do anything they were just running
on the trail like on the elliptical like
who cares there was a french guy that
lived across the street from my friend
Timmy and he was just kind of rude to us
once and we took two baseball bats we
were 10 years old across to his yard and
hit his tree into splinters just for no
reason we just we were like [__] you for
looking at us weird and then we threw
snowballs in his Open Door one day he
accidentally left the front door to his
house open we snowballs these are the
things you got at my my friend this
woman Jill who lived next to us um I me
and my friend would smoke pot in my
backyard when my parents you know my
mother wasn't home they had been
divorced
uh Jill would say things to us and we
used to grab butcher knives me and my
friend my chubby other little friend and
we were like 12 years old and we're like
we'll [__] kill you you dumb [__]
we'll cut your [__] head off you
[__] and she called the police and I
got a I got a person in need of
supervision a pins petition oh [__] I
talk about it in my book yeah but what's
interesting about it is that um you know
it was fun it was fun to do you know my
street had just a bunch of like people I
mean like you talked about Rescue 911
but I thought earlier you were talking
about Nanny 911 you remember that show
where people would it was it was the
same kind of concept where like it was
like a terrible home and they needed to
have a nanny come in to fix the
situation cuz the parents couldn't get
control of the
kids they shot an episode of that Cesar
Milan for kids yeah essentially yeah
they go like that they shot an episode
of that on my block and because the kids
were like un it was like across the
street from my best friends they would
just they were they were insane they
were throwing like hammers at people and
cars going by
911 dude it is cuz it's just the kids
were so out of control that they One on
Long Island it was like one of the most
I don't know if that if it's the Valente
one but it's like literally the most
it's one of the most uh Long Island's
always a legendary episode because
people can't imagine the animals that oh
yeah yeah well the parents are stunned
that their kids are acting up while
they're fist fighting drunk in the
kitchen that's why I love that show Wife
Swap where like they like they'll switch
it oh yeah switch the families switch
the families and like there'll be a
little fat kid who's like I'm not eating
that
salad and the woman's like this is what
we eat we eat vegetables and he's like
no I don't no it was unbelievable my
mama lets me eat Nessa quick chocolate
powder for dinner okay so is this the
one on Long Island I don't know if this
is the one on Long Island no the Long
Island one I haven't found yet but this
is just generic all right let's see this
find the Long Island one please okay
just some kids crying because Obama won
on Long Island
no he was a communist Community
organizer he's a Muslim he's married to
a man well all
true Nanny 911 is it the Lawrence just
hilarious is like you know the idea of a
guy being like the families are animals
the kids are mentally unstable they're
crazy it looked like such white trash
this was like you know they had like you
know people had this also pratal right
kind
of
Rin was in but uh what town is it Mike
just curious specifically it's in
C that's crazy you grew up in Cent reach
yeah wow they call it Santa Rico a lot
why heavily Puerto Rican racist that's
it's not racist it's just the
demographics it was Irish it was Irish
in Puerto Rican that's the type of guy
you want to
be is that Sebastian is that the kind of
guy you ever go over there at
Gaza
what are they doing over there can you
let the Italians cater to
pagram can we please let the Italian
skater to prgram a little better you're
eating what are you doing over
there I'm I'm um we watch some of this
sure
sure sitting here this is dead air
parents worst nightmare I told you stop
complaining kids completely out of
control
and taking over the
household 100% white kid of the RO get
they're in desperate need of help
spraying a kid with a h only have one
alternative left it's time to dial Nanny
911 hello this is Nanny
911 real nannies world class nannies
from all over the globe they all British
yeah oh wow I like that
family was a marry Poppin situation
you're going to end up like Princess
Diana if you don't get in that [__]
chair he always wore that the little
Cape they will then have one week to
take we'll do too what we did to the
Congo they're just like showing kids
playing they're going to have to be some
major changes that go on that's the plan
can these families be saved what a fun
show can these families be saved yeah it
turns out the ones on my block were not
able to all right all right is sick
very I'm sure it was nobody likes
anything better than watching something
horrible yeah like we've done you know
the TLC stuff which has gone crazy it's
like there's nothing there's nothing um
there's nothing more exciting to people
than watching you know that type of TV
but now the news has gotten so crazy
that there's no real like the reality
shows now yeah you can't compete with
China's got War in the Gulf we've got
warships in the Gulf that's why they're
going the opposite way they're doing
like the golden Bachelor oh this is
interesting like the old people Bachelor
it's feel good they're like oh look at
these people before they die trying to
find somebody they like it's a love
story yeah and off into the sunset
that's it dude cuz the divisive stuff
there was a time for that it's not
anymore it's not right now no it's
gotten too rough now yeah the real world
has gotten too rough you need to just do
like things about nice stuff people I
asked my mom about the whole Israel
Palestine thing and she was like have
you seen who moved to the next round
that America's Got Talent she's that's
the level she's like they have a dog who
juggles you know what I mean it's like
that's kind of where we're going towards
is a full well the dog's dead then we
don't know who killed it it was either a
missile that misfired from the
Palestinians or an air strike from
Israel but that dog was in a hospital
and now he's dead that dog has a yam by
the way where are we at on the hospital
who bombed the hospital who bomb the
hospital should be a segment who bomb
the hospital who bomb the hospital we
should have like a like like a duop
group
O who bomb the hospital
o who bomb the hospital 500 Dead who
bomb the hospital everybody thinks it
was Gaza but we don't know oh they have
visual analysis the visual analysis now
saying maybe this was a misfired rocket
from um H Hamas mhm and you've been
saying this the whole time to your
credit you've
been yeah you've been saying this the
whole time but I have been I I've been
unsure only because I like to get the
facts you like to gather information I
like to get the facts Davis fired right
from the hip he had the whole honeycomb
line thing he was he was but let's see
let's see let's see let's see show us
something that proves this please this
is also from Al jazer too oh oh boy hold
on this might be an ad oh yeah it is
hold on let's play out
jaer is uh remember they they first
started getting big during B lad right
Iraq yeah they aired Bin Laden's videos
they were the first to the mixtape right
yeah that's right they were Al and now
they're okay so let's let's watch a
little there it is let's watch a little
Al jazer there's the rocket the AL jazer
News Channel a rocket launch was visible
on the frame that's looking out over the
night sky
from other cameras we can clearly see
the launch of multiple Rockets the AL
jazer camera shows one of them that
appears to Veer off and break apart in
midair you can see obviously it fails
and flight and Spins out and
disintegrates it is not surprising a
number of weapons fail and it is well
known that a number of weapons will drop
inside Gaza and do drop inside Gaza and
do unfortunately kill civilians in Gaza
during it's not a surprising f it was
made in America small explosion seen on
the ground in the distance and then two
seconds later a much larger explosion
the time stamp that was on the screen
6:59 p.m. local time was the time that
the hospital was struck those time
stamps are in a very small time frame
that rocket was definitely launched from
within Gaza that a particular Hospital
based on a lot of geolocation patterns
does seem to line up with that General
geography likeone SS very condescending
telling us we're dumb for not
is is is Hamas saying it's Israel that
did that yes but I mean so there it
is and it's listen it's a horrible
tragedy like obviously we're here doing
jokes because this is our job to be
comedians but yeah this is not it's
awful this is awful and this is crazy
[__] you know what I mean like Jesus
Christ um this is inhuman and barbaric
that was a good album cover though was
the last
one it's like Against the Machine
burning parental advisory we're going
get we're going to get a fatwa against
us pretty soon that was Mike cannon that
yeah Canon so but I have said to any
Muslim listening who wants to kill me I
have said I'm not convinced Israel
didn't do this because maybe they have a
really good propaganda machine I don't
know but but maybe it was a misfired
rocket from
Gaza stop it Ian I mean I just feel like
someone's going to take the homb the
hospital out of context and autotune it
put a beat behind it that's going to be
something put the that's and then that's
the album
cover they said it was Gaza but it
wasn't Bo but it's like you know I mean
we we you know this is
brutal it's it's really crazy that
you're looking at these real scenes
of so much chaos death and destruction
and you know you're powerless to do much
about it like I know all these
celebrities signed a letter and God
bless are we sure that didn't end
everything though no I think they start
I think it was War I think people
started really killing each other after
that okay but I get it I understand
people going let's sign the letter but
here's the problem it feels kind of like
that imagine thing during Co sure does
it feels a lot like that right it's
tough and I just don't think BB
Netanyahu cares that Kate Blanchett yeah
and Hassan Minaj signed a letter you
don't think Jessica Chastain signature
is going to move I don't think it cares
galado signed a letter by the way that
said kill them
all so you want to talk about letters
entertainment industry a-listers signed
a letter to Biden urging a cizire in
Gaza and listen I would agree with that
but you also have to release all of
these hostages yeah that that you have
to do it here's the thing imagine this
works and Biden is like truly taking any
kind of I don't advise advice from
[__] celebrities no they're they're
their agent is going will you sign this
yeah they go okay they're signing it I'm
sure some of them are affected more than
others some of them you know like are
moam great comic gave an impassion
speech talked about this this is where
he comes from these are his people like
there are people people that are
genuinely speaking out from their own
experience they know people on the
ground they know things that are
happening that are real but then there's
also a lot of celebrities that are just
signing a letter because they want they
want things attention yeah or they they
want attention they probably they want
this to end and stuff but the reality is
it's just like I just don't know if this
country or if any country has ever
listened to celebrities signing a letter
no I I I don't I don't know that that's
ever been a factor well I like that they
they tried singing imagine they realized
that backfired so they're like let's go
old school let's do a letter well do you
think do you think Marilyn Monroe was
sucking JFK's dick and giving him advice
on the Bay of Pigs no no no but that's
when people knew their
place it was a simpler time a better
time yeah it was no but I mean the the
the reality here is that release hamas's
got to go we're releasing all of the
hostages mhm they got to say that they
and they got to release all the because
otherwise Israel's not going to stop
they'll just go to it'll be World War II
this is the reality and I and I know
people are like well what about all that
hostages in Palestine at two million
that Palestinian state they're not
debating that now you might debate that
in the future let's stick to what's
happening now you retards dumbest people
in the world to message me here's the
thing [__] what you have to do now is
you have to just end this immediate
situation anything else you want to do
can only be done dummies after you end
this immediate horrible situation that's
what you have to do then you can do
other things you're never going to do
those other things without ending this
immediate nightmare yeah then you go to
the table then you go to the table with
other things and go we need to figure
something out that will never happen
unless all those hostages aren't freed
and then there is a ceasefire and Israel
does not do a ground assault it's a big
mistake to do a ground assault in Gaza
it's Urban Warfare it's crazy it's
trench it's a bad idea a dude it's a bad
bad idea yeah how could they possibly go
in there with any confidence and then
what happens you evict all these people
throw them out then what what do you do
take over Gaza you run Gaza it's it'll
never be a good idea they is Israeli
troops will be sitting ducks for more
attacks if they're in G it's a very bad
idea Thomas Freedman to the New York
Times I make fun of all the time but
he's right about this I make fun of him
because he says dumb things he's like
the world has gone from connected to
hyperconnect it's like can you
please has all these word things I hate
but he's right about this it's it's a
mistake to go into occupy It On The
Ground yeah this is Iraq and Afghan this
is all of this stuff this is going into
the mountains and the tunnels this is a
bad idea why would we do it this is a
bad idea and they want us involved they
want America involved they want American
troops we're already footing the bill
we're already footing the bill this is a
big mistake you know after 911 we did a
lot of bad [__] and we destabilized a
lot of countries and the reality of the
situation is don't you don't want to
make that mistake the question is who
who do you think think actually wrote
that letter who is the actual person who
sat down and wrote that thing that they
all signed dear President Biden we come
together as artists and Advocates but
but most importantly as human beings
witnessing devastating loss of lives
unfolding Horrors in his
pal it's a it's probably UNICEF we
believe that the United States can play
a diplomatic role in ending the
suffering we're adding our voes those
from the Congress UNICEF Doctors Without
bords International Committee of the Red
Cross I imagine it's some un yeah
subcommittee like it's well we were
talking about it last night that they
with the Imagine video with stuff like
this they've almost become the anti-
influencer where the things that they
stand for people are having an adverse
reaction to it because it's disingenuous
so and because it's all over the [__]
place and because it's mostly
self-serving so as soon as people see
that the general celebrity populace is
on board with something they're
automatically like I yeah I'm off this
there's nothing really that can be
done for such a conflict that is
so layered and it's been going on for so
long you have a four paragraph letter
yeah that says we would like it to stop
yeah please and we're famous I mean to
be fair that is how we started this show
what by saying we would like it to end
deescalate and stop it well I have only
said that
I have said that as someone who the only
reason I want it to stop is because I
want to start a war there oh I want more
Bloodshed I'm for the death of children
I'm going at it from the other way I
want
nukes I want a Christian crusade to kill
them all all that's what I'm
saying where's the ad do you have an ad
now somebody want to do an ad anybody
want to do an ad now
I'm Pro Christian Crusade that's why I'd
like this to stop so we can have time to
lose weight so we can go in there no
matter where your adventures take you
this fall bespoke post has a box of
awesome to make it just that more
awesome the box of awesome is filled
with carefully chosen gear from the best
small Brands around the world let's see
what I got this month I got a box and it
had all kinds of cool stuff it had some
camping gear Essentials and Autumn
cocktail upgrades it's had cozy threads
box of awesome has collections for every
part of your life to get started take
the quiz at box ofawesome.com your
answers will help them pick right box of
awesome for you they release new boxes a
month across a ton of different
categories each box is valued at around
$70 but you only pay a fraction of that
price plus with each box of awesome
you're supporting small businesses 90%
of everything that comes in your box of
awesome is from a small upand cominging
brand it's free to sign up and you can
skip a month or cancel any time get 20%
off your first monthly box when you sign
up at box ofawesome.com and after the
code Tim Dylan a checkout that's box
ofawesome.com code Tim Dyan for 20% off
your first Box Box ofawesome.com codee
Tim t m d i l l o n by the way get this
story up most of the American Military
is fat but who cares there's nothing
more American than fat people killing
others do you know what I so I went over
there to perform for the troops you you
did and this was interesting I did and
one of the most one of the things that I
had the toughest time grasping was that
their meals you know we're getting free
meals over there on the base all that
[__] but we're talking to them their
meals come out of their paycheck so
they're [__] paying for their lunch
for their meals out of their own pockets
it's AB isn't it [__] nuts that's
absurd right I right as soon as I
express get I mean it's it's fine it's
fine cafeteria food but it's just
chicken patties yeah it's spaghetti and
meatball and somebody told me on a mil
one of the military bases in Afghanistan
there was like 70,000 people they had
like a whole boardwalk of like fast food
restaurants and everything on the
military base it was crazy there there
there was one in Bahrain that was really
like kind kind of the party base it
didn't seem like anything was really
going on there but it it yeah that stuff
was they were paying for their food and
then when we brought it up to them they
were kind of just like no it's like how
was the show the shows were unbelievable
they were the best shows I've ever done
I did one on Veteran's Day in a theater
in Kuwait and they like presented us
with all of these things being so
grateful I had just gotten bit by a
marine dog that day like you know I put
on the FL jacket I was kicking it
telling it to
why did well so and it was just an
amazing time because they're very
grateful yeah they were so grateful but
then you know you see it and also the
cafeteria you think these people they're
soldiers right they're doing intense
laborious [__] they're going out there
to [__] take care of business and
they're feeding them sometimes like
burgers and heavy [__] and you're like I
understand the Comforts of home and you
need to remind them of that but they
should be fed like their super athletes
that's not carbo load yeah you know what
I mean yeah maybe but
well here's the deal they're just there
to kill people right at the end of the
day working you know we're just there to
kill people you know I mean we could
dress it up any way we want but they're
just there to kill I think there's
anything wrong with that you don't you
want us to have abs while we do it no I
think it's actually funner and cooler if
you send a bunch of fat guys over there
to kill the kids they pulling their
shirt down they're just there to kill
11-year-olds that they think might have
bombs trapped to them so they're just
going to shoot them in the face but I'm
glad they enjoyed your
show
I'm kidding military obesity rat sore
compounding recruitment challenges
Services still struggling to find
eligible applicant because everyone in
the military now has gotten to be a big
whale but here's the good news we're
fighting high tech Wars with drones and
all kinds of like Precision Weaponry
we've invested so much money billions
trillions of dollars into DARPA the
defense Advanced research projects
agency we have like alien technology
happening we are so there's nothing more
American than a fat guy playing a video
game and wiping out people 100% there's
nothing more American than that just a
big fat slob just in a room killing
everyone disconnected from the humanity
all I'm not into that SEAL Team Six
where everybody's ripped up and Seal
training SEAL training should be nothing
you know what SEAL training should be
you should walk in a room they should
hand you a Big Mac and they should go
they should put photos of people of all
different ages and genders and
everything and go who won't you
kill and then a guy's like I kill them
all there you go you're in you're a Navy
SEAL now you push this button and
just and that's what it is because we
need people to not be [__] we need
them to press buttons and get it done
yeah we don't need hot people in the I
mean it's nice yeah I'm old I guess I'm
old school in that way I'm thinking
about it boots on the ground but what
you're saying is new that's the new age
war is is just get slovenly people that
are have no problem pressing a button
they probably won't even feel it their
fingertips are numb I know there's some
great people in the military phenomenal
people in the military and then I know
some other people yeah you know just
like cops for sure friends that became
you know yeah and it's a it's a
courageous thing to do we need a great
military I don't have the balls to do it
I respect everybody who does yeah you
know what I mean I used to suck off this
24-year-old Marine who from Southern
California who was kind of [__] was
he ripped though he was ripped had a
sixpack but he was [__] yeah and he
didn't understand what was happening
ever yeah I'm not talking about I mean
he wasn't that [__] but I mean like
he you know he was just like he that was
a dangerous he didn't understand what
was
happening there was no consent he just
playing with
butterflies I might everyone's Pro rape
here we're all pro rape i' I've got I
mean it's like Chrystal is doing that
music festival Israel next year they B
him
already stop it Diana did it Diana said
I didn't even say it here's the point
there's a lot of people who are just you
know they just a lot of people just I
get it if they we let kill them they go
we got to do it and you got to do it I
met a kid when I was over there he was
18 years old from Kansas he looked like
a baby and I and I was talking to him I
was like so what do you do he's like man
he's like I wanted to be in [__]
infantry I want to be on Theo on the
ground he's like turns out I'm [__]
smart he's like so now I'm behind a
computer yeah like he's like livid that
he doesn't get to kill people face to
face but sometimes that's where they
need to go yeah people that want to kill
others should go into our military yeah
that's you know because we don't want
them doing that I mean we have the best
murderers and homicides in the in the
world right I mean we should be we have
good ones but we've seen some send some
of Chicago out there yeah that's right
that's a real Boomer that's Boomer you
know it's like the
Boomer
hey about Chicago you go over there how
about you kill people over there instead
of killing them in your back in guns are
illegal there and look what's going on
about D you go over here you join the
military that way when you die your
family gets something for it literally I
it was once we were in a in a mall and a
Scott's military recruiter he went up to
this guy and he was like he was like
he's like you should join the military
and it was a black guy black guy goes
where I'm from there is a war and the
military recruiter goes yeah but when
you die overseas at least your family
gets something for it literally he said
that in the in the Long Island Mall holy
[__]
crazy so like you know the kids like all
right it makes sense that guy killed
Osama Bin Laden but I mean it's like did
you ever think about going into the
military no my friends as a prank signed
me up for the Marines um they I'm not
kidding they they gave them they went to
a recruitment center and then they gave
them my information my phone number my
address and they called um multiple
times a week for months until happened
my mom got on the phone with them and
they make they made good points uh and
then my mom got on the phone with them
and screamed until they uh they my son's
a terrorist we have the same story my
friends didn't I don't know if my
friends signed me up but I spent like 90
minutes on the phone with a recruiter
cuz I just didn't know what was I was
like [__] and just walking around my
house talking this guy and then my mom
got on the phone and started screaming
it was like not not coming it does feel
like there is that thing of like watch I
tell you I'm watching B of Brothers but
there is something about that where you
go I I watch that I watch even Full
Metal Jacket you're supposed to get this
feeling of like War as hell this is all
thing I watch that I'm like man what
camaraderie that looks that looks great
that's because you didn't play sports if
you played team sports you would have
had that I say one thing that might not
be great for everyone in the room say it
through Diana and my own career
everyone knows that
trick I'm a very bad ventril yeah I'm
leaving out the activities that happened
when they landed did the paragliders not
look
fun just as a thing like was there a
moment of fun no dude when you're doing
I didn't even know that was a thing I
never even knew that I don't want to do
that to kill people I want to do it at
like Sandals Resort yeah do you think do
you know what I mean a couple we were
exclaimed I'm just saying it looked like
I thought it was like a fun if you saw
that at South by Southwest yeah it was
just like look at this fun thing I there
should be some sort of squirrel suit Red
Bull helmet yeah I was like this can't
end in the murder because it's just f it
looked fun you know but it's so but I'm
happy that our I love that our parents
were like our sons will not sacrifice
one were you ever close no no no no I
remember after 911 I felt for a minute
like it'd be cool to have a job as like
a CIA agent this is when you don't know
anything you're in like 11th grade it'
be cool to do something that mattered
because like you're like [__] you know
things are real now and I want to do
something that matters like being a
military or work for like a top secret
you know and then that wears off within
months yeah I my roommate in college was
uh doing like Roc and signing up and he
was like six foot five he looked like a
GI Joe and he was
excited beyond belief about going over
to Afghanistan like he was well there's
a lot of guys that joined for patriotic
reasons they go we want to help and we
want to like actually like you know we
don't want this [__] to happen right we
need a military as much as we K around
about it we need people to go over there
and [__] [__] up when people threaten us
1,000% we just need to put them in in
winnable situations he he was he would
often talk about the excitement of
killing like looking forward to killing
people yeah
sure sure just watching the
breath of body also that the way he
described it was you know a very
specific the w a very specific slur but
yeah I mean he was uh he was out of it
but it was it was it was out of
patriotism it was yeah and that's nice
yeah you need some you need some you
know you know PE people when I was
driving in a
tunnel and because I was by the way I
was about to be married to a big
Egyptian and and he was about to be a
Muslim in the British royal family so
mr6 and the Mad had me killed in the
tunnel and they said that the Press did
it which never made any sense to anybody
they said that the
press the people with cameras caused my
limosine to crash and the it's not true
and now my son has married a black girl
all right you know this is not go right
in the cup this is not what we want this
is not what what we want um this is a
fun episode do we do we think this stays
on you do you think they'll leave this
on you not a
chance do you think this will stay on
YouTube I think it'll get all the gates
it'll get uh you know AG gated and we'll
get ad suitability red everything yeah
it'll get blocked but maybe for a couple
it'll be good couple that means it's
good it was a good run yeah yeah that
means it's good all right I'll be back
solo next week but I really like these
guys so I figured we would go we would
go and have a lot of fun and I think
we've done that yeah had a good time
we've done that you know and that's all
we can do your new special tell people
where to get it uh new comedy special
youtube.com/ mikf comedy it's Mike fenia
night at the comedy seller I directed it
and edited it it's out on October 27th
please go watch it on Canon Live dates
coming up live dates also I'm the
co-host of Chrissy chaos with chrisan
Chris Deano that's uh that's going to be
super fun in uh November I'm going to be
in levitown Long Island at a Governor's
baby when is that November 3rd and 4th
are you in town I'm in Rochester
November 3rd but November 4th I may just
pull up to hang out come hang for sure
that'll be good time uh and then I'm be
in DC in uh December December 8th and
9th I got some Florida dates as well but
I'm all over the road and uh yeah Mye
Canon comedy.com for all that Tim
comedy.com we're on sale very soon with
uh shows in Boston and DC and all these
places but uh Rochester New York
Pittsburgh Houston San Diego Toronto
Austin Brea columb
Pennsylvania Washington Northfield Ohio
San Antonio Dallas Atlanta St Louis
Indianapolis Boston and then Foxwoods we
also have dates coming in London Dublin
Glasgow H or Edinburgh and uh Manchester
maybe I don't know anyway uh and that'll
be the end of the tour so the next two
three months that's it we do appreciate
it and uh thank you everybody for
listening and again we hope this stays
uh available it will I think your open
yeah all right thank you everyone good
night